Japanese coast guards circling this wreckage of a house swept away by the March 11 tsunami...
...got quite a surprise when they came in for a closer look.
Scrambling out from beneath the rubble, a dog emerges.
Seeming to have defied incredible odds,...
...the dog is believed to have survived not only the tsunami,...
...but three weeks at sea as well.
The house had been washed away not far from the Kesennuma coast in northern Japan...
...when a magnitude nine earthquake triggered a devastating tsunami.
Seemingly scared by the helicopter's propellers, the dog hid under the roof of the house,...
...forcing rescuers to descend and try to lure it to safety.
It was eventually rescued by a coast guard boat when the helicopter reportedly ran out of fuel.
Japanese broadcaster NTV said the coast guards were hoping the dog would help lead them to its owner.
A massive search and recover operation is currently underway...
...to find around 18,000 people still missing...
...and now presumed dead, three weeks after the disaster struck.
Nick Rowlands, Reuters.